after a shooting in a newsroom the media
jumps you anti-trump conclusions Supreme
Court talk heats up and we'll check the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
Oh tons to talk about today and we will
get to all of it first I want to remind
you that we have a special livestream
coming up this Monday July 2nd 7:00 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific we're going to be
joined by special guest Jordan Peterson
to celebrate Independence Day because
he's the world's foremost Canadian God
King Jeremy boring he's gonna host a new
edition of daily wire backstage with me
and Andrew Clavin in the execrable
Michael Mills to look back on our
country's birth and look ahead to its
future with an ignoramus like Knowles
and a very well informed Canadian like
Jordan Peterson subscribers will even be
able to write in live questions for us
to answer on the air again that is this
Monday July 2nd 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific with special guest Jordan
Peterson you can find our special live
storm on Facebook and YouTube you're not
going to want to miss it also you're
going to want to check out o Max and the
reason for that is because you're not as
healthy as you could be omega-3s have
been touted as one of the healthiest
supplements you can find but the reality
is they're even healthier than that try
Oh max calm / appear and get a box for
free that's about free box of Oh max 3
ultra pure which is the purest omega-3
supplement on the market over 75% of
Americans don't get enough Omega threes
in their diet you're probably one of
them so here's why they're important to
your health really and they can improve
focus and memory they can boost your
cardiovascular health they can alleviate
joint pain and here's the problem a lot
of the ones that you're saying in the
market a lot of these Omega threes you
see on the market they are not pure
enough o max 3 ultra pure is almost
ninety four percent pure omega-3 fatty
acids it's so pure that you can do with
it what they call the freezer test
challenge basically if you take any
other omega-3 and you stick it in a
freezer and you take it out it's gonna
look cloudy because that's all the
filler but if you put o max 3 soft gel
in there it remains clear because it is
that pure is clinically tested so it's
safe for you and your family
well max 3 is the purest most potent
most concentrated omega-3 on the market
you're gonna want to use it whether
you're an athlete whether you're a
student whether you're just somebody who
needs a little bit more focus Oh max 3
comes with a 60-day money-back
guarantees you have plenty of time to
try it and really feel that Oh max
difference you're really not risking
anything at all go to try Oh max calm /
Shapiro today to get a box of Oh max 3
ultra pure for free that's try Oh max
calm / compare to get your free box of
Oh max 3 T ry om a XCOM / Shapiro Terms
& Conditions
to apply ok so yesterday there's a
horrific event and it happens at a
newsroom in Annapolis Maryland at a
place called the Capitol Gazette
nobody's ever heard of the Capitol
Gazette newspaper because a local
newspaper and a
walked into the building and proceeded
to gun down a bunch of people killed at
least five people and this shooter was a
peculiar human being shall we say aside
from being evil he apparently damaged
his finger so that he could not be
identified and then the investigators
had to use facial recognition to
identify him and the shooter had a
history with the newspaper it turns out
because he had sued them in 2012 for
defamation after there was a story by a
person who wrote for the paper about how
this guy had basically harassed her
online and then he sued for defamation
and he lost the Capitol Gazette reported
in 2015 the suspects lawsuit against the
newspaper had been thrown out by a judge
because the article is based on public
records and the suspect presented no
evidence that it was inaccurate the
Capitol Gazette reported at the time
that the suspect who represented himself
appealed the decisions in the Maryland
Court of Special Appeals which upheld
the ruling in an opinion that was filed
that day a lawyer would almost certainly
have told him not to proceed with the
case the court wrote it reveals a
fundamental failure to understand what
defamation law is it more particularly
what's information law is not so why is
this national news aside from the fact
that it's yet another mass shooting on
American soil
the reason it's national news is because
everybody decided it was very important
to jump to conclusions so a bunch of
people decided online that they were
going to jump to the conclusion that
this person had been inspired by my
lowly innopolis now I've been loath to
say the name Maile Ohye Annapolis
because I find him alone some human
being but Milo in Annapolis has been
sort of an ultra provocateur for several
years he's the kind of fellow who one
sent me on my son's birthday a picture
of a black child because I was a cuck
right I was somebody didn't care enough
about the whiteness of the United States
and thus I would not have minded if my
wife slept with a black person and had a
and had a black child that's the kind of
person Maile Ohye annapolis is well my
Lily had said a couple of days ago he
was in a couple of exchanges with
journalists and he had written back to a
journalist that he hopes the journalist
gets shot so the entire left decided
this was my Lully Annapolis his fault
the shooting and then they decided also
that it was Donald Trump's fault the
shooting this is before we actually knew
why this guy had gone and committed the
shooting in the first place and as I say
it turns out the reason that he
committed the shooting is because a
nutjob who had filed suit against the
newspaper and had a vendetta against the
newspaper but did not stop the media
from trying to blame Donald Trump
yesterday over all this now none of this
is to say that Miley innopolis is
worried about journalists aren't
execrable and terrible they are
execrable and terrible but lots of
people say execrable terrible things
that does not mean
they are responsible for the actual
shooting of other human beings unless
you are actually telling people to go
shoot journalists you're not responsible
for somebody going and shooting
journalists this is why when Bernie
Sanders was blamed for the Congressional
baseball shooting by some I said this is
not on Bernie Sanders I don't like
Bernie Sanders I don't like anything the
Bernie Sanders says but we're on a very
dangerous slope here if we're gonna
blame speech for the actions of people
who are crazy who go out and shoot other
people well the administration
immediately came out and condemned the
attack of course Sarah Huckabee Sanders
has asked about it and she condemned the
attacks and strongly condemn the evil
act of senseless violence in Annapolis
Maryland a violent attack on innocent
journalists doing their job as an attack
on every American our prayers are with
the victims and their friends and
families and it wasn't just Sarah
Huckabee Sanders president Trump also
tweeted out in Sweden
prior to departing Wisconsin I was
briefed on the shooting at Capitol
Gazette in Annapolis Maryland my
thoughts and prayers are with the
victims and their families thank you to
all the first responders who are
currently on the scene okay so it's a
perfectly nice tweet from president
Trump Mike Pence did the same the vice
president he tweeted something out just
arrived in Guatemala we're monitoring
the horrific shooting at the Capitol
Gazette in Annapolis Karen and I are
praying for the victims and their
families we commend the swift action by
law enforcement and all the first
responders on the scene okay so how does
the media cover all this did they cover
this as a nutjob went into a newspaper
he had a vendetta against with the
shotgun and murdered a bunch of people
no they covered this as though as
Trump's fault because they have no sense
of perspective because they have no
sense of their own hypocrisy these are
the same people who are in many ways
defending Maxine Waters in her call for
sort of mob confrontation a lot of these
folks are the same people who are
laughing about you know the various
Kathy Griffin stunts with the heads of
Donald Trump and such these same people
are saying that it is Donald Trump's
fault
when a person who is totally
unassociated with Donald Trump goes out
and shoots up a newsroom and they dug up
a tweet from 2015 in which the guy
suggested that anti-trump bias could be
met with violence but again they say
this is the he tweeted something like
that you can bring that tweet back up
he had tweeted something to the effect
of that the he had tweeted something
like the newspaper was unqualified and
it could end badly again he tweeted some
of the shooter tweeted referring to
Donald Trump is unqualified could end
badly again okay well he wrote that in
2015 which is about the time that he had
filed his lawsuit his lawsuit against
the news
paper had been dismissed and Donald
Trump and filed a lawsuit against
Univision so basically you know the only
threat that I can see there is a lawsuit
threat even though this guy was
completely not but a bunch of people in
the media decided that this is Trump's
fault the Trump's language about
journalists the fact that journalists
are booed at all of his rallies the fact
that people chance CNN sucks this is
responsible for some unrelated nutjob
going out and shooting up a newsroom
even though it's very obvious that this
guy went in Trump the newsroom because
he had a vendetta against the people at
the newsroom so brian Stelter for
example on CNN he says this is the
moment that so many journalists have
feared it's a moment that I think so
many journalists have feared for a long
time regardless of whether this newsroom
was targeted or not this has been a fear
on many journalists Minds okay so it's
not that it's not a fear of many
journalists mind okay it isn't as a
journalist for nearly my entire life an
opinion journalist for my entire adult
life I can say that I don't have
significant fear that people are gonna
randomly come into our daily wire
offices and start shooting the place up
unless I were talking about an actual
politically motivated attack for spelter
to say that as though journalists have a
special fear is just weird okay the fact
is that journalists are not routinely
targeted by the general public and what
he's really implying there is that the
the tenor of anti media activity has
grown so strong that people are going to
go out and shoot people so he's
attempting to and backhanded fashion I
think blame President Trump and it's not
just him there's a political reporter
Josh Meyer in DC who tweeted something
out similar he said every journalist and
those who support us should retweet this
I can't think of a single other
president in my lifetime who would have
acted like this perhaps he fears
questions about whether his anti media
rhetoric played a role and those Josh
Meyer referring to President Trump being
asked about the Maryland shooting so
hero reporters harassing Trump about the
Maryland shooting yesterday
[Music]
okay so then the reporters are screaming
at him and they're yelling at him
this happens virtually every day okay
I've been to the White House several
times and every day the president comes
out and pours screen on him and he
doesn't answer their questions it's
actually pretty rare that the President
breaks off and does like an impromptu
press conference over this whole thing
he tweeted out what he thought about it
but this is being taken by Politico and
others as evidence that Trump doesn't
care if journalists get shot and then
Maggie Haberman who's reporting I
generally think is good she came out she
did sort of the same thing she tweeted
this out she tweeted out because the New
York Times reporter the near Times
reporter blaming Trump as Maggie
Haberman saying supporting local
journalism is important what happened
today is sickening this alleged gunman
appears to have had a long-standing
grudge against the paper and little else
is known so far but Trump is the only
president in memory to call the press
the enemy of the people well there's no
connection between Trump doing that and
the guy shooting up the newsroom that
this is the attempt to make a connection
two strains make a connection between
Trump's language and the shooting I
think his is foolhardy now again I don't
like Trump slang which was her card to
the press I've been very critical of
President Trump's language with regard
to the press when they report on fake
news I think that is perfectly who I
think is perfectly appropriate for him
to say that fake news is fake news when
it's fake news but his tendency to call
the press the enemy of the people I
don't like I never have liked it I've
always thought that it was a serious
problem but the attempt to paint that as
responsible for a shooting that he had
nothing to do with is really quite
amazing it really is and again it was it
was many members of the media doing this
routine yesterday for example the
editor-in-chief of Reuters tweeted
something out along these lines is the
tweet from from this is 17 so this is
the the statement that was put out by
Steve Adler who's editor-in-chief of
Reuters
regarding the Rob Cox tweet so the
breaking views editor Rob Cox actually
tweeted about the shooting in Annapolis
let's see the tweet first and then the
response from Reuters so you said this
is what happens when Donald Trump calls
journalists the enemy of the people
blood is on your hands mr. president
save your thoughts and prayers for your
empty soul at least four people killed
in Maryland newspaper shooting reports
okay so he's blaming President Trump for
all of this in the fact that the media
are eager to leap to this but for
example when President Obama was
incentivizing
it's in places like Ferguson in
Baltimore or when cops were shot in
Dallas the media rightly said that this
is not true this is not Obama's fault
it's not Obama's fault the cops got shot
in Dallas by a black lives matter ally
that's not Obama's fault so it's not
even black lives matters fault I think
but the media was in a real hurry to
defend President Obama over that but
they are in a real hurry to blame
President Trump for this particular
shooting so all of this is just
disgusting because if you're going to
blame somebody for actual violence
against somebody else you ought to have
some evidence that the violence is
connected to the thing that somebody
said as an journalist should be shot
somebody goes out reads that tweet says
great tweet now I'm negotiate
journalists okay that that is a fair
connection but to connect vague language
with regard to how much you dislike the
media and how you hate the media with
somebody going and shooting up members
of the media if we're gonna do that then
every shooting in the United States can
be tied to somebody else's First
Amendment protected rhetoric because
here's the reality incitements is not
protected under the First Amendment if I
say Mathis shoots Enya okay that is not
protected under the First Amendment if
Mathis goes and shoots Enya I actually
bear some criminal liability for
incitement okay but the same thing is
not true if I would say you know sending
is a really terrible producer and I rip
something bad should happen to send you
like that isn't that's actually First
Amendment protected make me a piece of
crap right it would make it be a bad
thing to say but it doesn't actually
mean that I'd be responsible for
something bad happening to send you by
the way nothing bad should happen to
sending us I mean is wonderful but all
of this said it really is it's it's
amazing to watch as the media
immediately mobilized to make a
narrative out of something that does not
meet the standards for that narrative
okay in just a second I want to talk
about how the left is again embracing a
certain level of violent rhetoric and
and violence that is really disturbing
there to talk about president Trump
being violent in his rhetoric and the
left it certainly does not have clean
hands on this I have a clip from Michael
Moore I want to show you in just a
second all about this but first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors
overexpress VPN so with all the recent
news about data hacks breaches it's hard
for me not to worry about my digital
privacy because the fact is that you
know I figure that people are always
trying to grab my data whether I'm at a
public Wi-Fi or whether I'm just online
generally every website you visit it's
pretty clear that every email you send
oh there are too many people who
couldn't have eyes on your stuff and
that's why you need a VPN and you really
should have expressed VPN expressvpn is
the world's leading VPN provider
and lets you securely use the internet
without being tracked by anyone which is
the way the Internet should be
expressvpn keeps my online activity
private in anonymous while I browse
email tail notice stream expressvpn is
great for streaming content as well you
can watch the World Cup without a cable
subscription which if that's your thing
it's pretty awesome expressvpn cost less
than seven bucks a month and runs
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone or tablet it is super
easy to set up in the first place
they're easy to use the app encrypts all
my Internet's and it has my IP address
it protects my entire connection take
back your internet privacy today find
out how you can get three months for
free so go over to expressvpn dot-com
slash man I use Express VPN again it was
super easy to set up and it really is
terrific expressvpn comm slash been for
three months free with one year package
exp ress VPN comm slash been for three
months free with the one-year package
again via expressvpn comm slash been to
let them know that we sent you okay so
while the media have focused deeply in
on president Trump's rhetoric about the
press to suggest that he is responsible
for a whack-job who had vendetta against
a newspaper shooting up the newspaper
you've got people on the Left who are
mainstreaming mob action one of those
people is Michael Moore Michael Moore
has a new movie out called Fahrenheit 11
9 or it soon will be out Fahrenheit 11 9
of course this is a play on Fahrenheit
9/11 11 9 of course this time refers to
the fact that Donald Trump was elected
because this is an emergency for our
republic the clip that he showed from
his movie by the way is just awful now
I'm supposed to be on Bill Maher tonight
and I'm really disappointed because I'm
I can only be on Bill Maher for the
first 15 minutes of the show I would
love to be on Bill Maher show for the
full hour because then I'd be on a panel
with Michael Moore and I could ask him
about his his terrible preview but I
can't actually do that because Sabbath
that's coming in early talking to the
first 15 minutes of the show then I'm
looking forward to that but Michael
Moore will be on the show tonight as
well Michael Moore was on Stephen
Colbert last night pushing his new movie
and he started talking about instability
in our culture listen to how Michael
Moore describes incivility because it
really is telling the same left that
says that we should really ratchet down
the rhetoric
something with which I generally agree
the same left well at the same time say
well but I don't really apply that to
you know like treatment of conservatives
or treatment of Republicans like that's
a different thing entirely here's
Michael Moore cause that are coming from
the uncivil asking Democrats who are
usually so wimpy and weak and know it's
okay you know we will take half of
versal healthcare we don't need the
whole thing you know that's how our
sight sounds all the time we're
constantly giving in and then a few
people want to stand up and say no I've
had enough that's it and we don't have
to be violent we have to remain
nonviolent but you know if the worst
that's gonna happen to anybody in the
Trump administration is that they don't
get to have a chicken dinner in in
Virginia I mean I don't know the only
way that we're going to stop this is
eventually we're all gonna have to put
our bodies on the line you're gonna have
to be willing to do this it is funny I
was having lunch with with a
particularly famous Hollywood player
yesterday whose name shall remain
anonymous so he can continue to get jobs
and we were doing so at a restaurant in
the middle of Beverly Wood yesterday and
I was just looking around we were
talking he was a trump supporter and we
were just looking around and noting that
this is a Tony Ritchie restaurant
everybody in this restaurant is earning
significant six-figure money this is
this is a very very glamorous place and
we're sitting I'm looking around and I
realized that everyone who is there
sipping their their bubbly water
everybody there who is sipping their
their their Chardonnay in the middle of
the afternoon
all those people think that we are
living in the middle of a civil war and
in the middle of a crisis right as
they're sitting there sipping their
Chardonnay they think that we are living
in the middle of a fascist takeover of
the United States and it's just
astonishing that this is how they think
like all those people would be nodding
along to Michael Moore saying we need to
put our bodies on the line as they sit
there eating their $200 lunches having
driven there in their Porsches and it
occurred to me that this is all
delusional this is all delusional listen
we're in the political space a lot we
spend all of our day in the political
space I spend all my day in the
political space and it's easy to get
caught up in the back and forth it's
easy to feel that politics is really
fraught right now but the reality is if
you took somebody from 1930 and you
plunk them down in the middle of 2018
they would literally think they died
went to heaven they would literally
think that right then get anything they
want at any time for any reason they are
not going to be poor because poverty in
the United States is better than wealthy
people were living in 1920 okay and yet
we still think that were in the middle
of this massive civil war that that has
to stop in a second I'm gonna explain
why that has to stop so the reason that
the reason that we have to stop with the
crisis mentality is because crisis
mentality leads P
to the belief that harsh sometimes evil
action is necessary and sitting around
in a place like Los Angeles while the
Sun streams through the big windows and
everybody is eating their lobster you
know I had a coke well everybody is
doing that it just it occurs to you that
the more we we think that our neighbors
our enemies the more likely we are to
start anticipating tactics that are that
are bad so the the shooting that
happened in Maryland has nothing to do
with President Trump but I don't think
that it's I don't think it's
questionable that the temperature in the
country has risen to a certain extent
I'm trying to be reflective about this
as I possibly can and honest with you I
think the temperature in the cousin in
the country has risen to a level that is
unsustainable and I think it's based on
nearly nothing
I think our political differences matter
an awful lot I think politics matter an
awful lot I think our rights matter an
awful lot and I think that some of our
rights are at crisis point in terms of
our defense of those rights but I don't
think that we are at the point where
Americans are ready to put their bodies
on the line as Michael Moore says that
it's time to see this as a civil war in
any real way then there there may be an
intellectual civil war going on but that
intellectual civil war has been going on
for generations in the United States
maybe it's a little worse now than it
was any time since 1960s but I just I
don't buy into the idea that that this
is a time that is deserving of the kind
of vitriol and insanity that we are
seeing and it's being promulgated by
people on both sides but particularly on
the left right now because what the left
is doing is they're doing what Michael
Moore does which is I love civility
civility is great but I can't be civil
with these evil Republicans so civility
must end Maxine Waters the case in
points of this so Maxine Waters has now
said the representative who said just
earlier this week that there should be
mob justice against a bunch of people
going to gas stations if you disagree
with them she said on Thursday she's in
it seen an increase in threats since she
made controversial comments encouraging
protesters to heckle and harass members
of trumps cabinet in public spaces she
said that she got threatening messages
in hostile mail at her offices she
canceled two scheduled appearances in
Alabama and Texas she can sense you got
one very serious death threat on Monday
from an individual in Texas and she's as
the president has continued to lie and
falsely claim that I encourage people to
assault his supporters while also
offering a veiled threat that I should
be careful even more individuals are
threatened leaving threatening messages
and sending hostile mail to my office
I mean this is indicative of the way
that our politics is working right now
Maxine Waters doesn't like when anybody
attempts to assault her because no one
would like that because it's terrible
stuff but then she'll go out and
encourage people to assault people at
gas stations and she didn't encourage
people to us all people of gas stations
the word of salt by the way does not
mean battery and in the legal
terminology she encouraged people to get
in people's faces at gas stations and
threaten them okay that is not battery
batteries when I hit you assault is when
I threaten you she did encourage that
there's no question she encouraged that
and she felt okay encouraging that cuz
it was somebody on the other side so in
other words everybody is in favor of
civility as long as it applies to people
on their own side but nobody is in favor
of civility when it's applied to people
on the other side and the reality is
that we live in the most civil of times
violence in the United States is it 50
or lowes it is the the level of vitriol
maybe in a 50 or high but violence in
the United States it is in 50 or low
we're living a pretty paradisiacal
situation the economy is doing great
there is no excuse for this level of
insanity in our current politics and yet
everybody continues to go insane and
that's only being exacerbated of course
I'm at the situation with the Supreme
Court because now that Justice Kennedy
has stepped down the left is fully
convinced that the right is coming for
everything that they hold dear not
understanding of course how the supreme
court works in the first place having
used the supreme court as the tool of
they're leftist politics for denying 80
years at this point the Democrats are
now firmly convinced that the
Republicans are gonna come in they're
gonna swoop in with the Supreme Court at
their behest and they're going to run
roughshod over everybody's rights and
we'll be living in a Nazi state this
kind of insane over-the-top talk is not
good for the country and again I think
there are a lot of people in the country
who right now feel justified in being
uncivil incivility can bleed into
violence I'm not going to blame people
who are uncivil for violence but I will
say that when you raise the temperature
every so often you're going to get the
pot boiling over right when when the
temperature is room-temperature in the
pot it doesn't boil over ever when the
temperature is a little bit high and
then you put the lid on then it is more
likely that the pot is going to boil
over I think that the likelihood the pot
is going to boil over right now is a lot
higher than it has been in the past and
there is no real excuse for it so I'm
gonna talk in a second about this
fallout from the Supreme Court but first
let's talk about the national debt 21
trillion bucks and Counting our national
debt money we owe other countries it is
greater than the entire economic output
of the United States if your life
savings is tied to the US dollar you
might want to ask
yourself what is your plan for inflation
what happens if the Chinese begin
selling our bonds hedge against
inflation and hedge against uncertainty
and instability with precious metals
gold is a safe haven against uncertainty
my savings plan is diversified yours
should be too doesn't mean you should
sell all your stock and put it all in
precious metals but you should certainly
have some of your money in precious
metals and the company I trust with
precious metal purchases is Birch gold
group right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver it's perfect
for people who want to protect their
hard-earned retirement savings from any
future geopolitical uncertainty look
back historically when the bottom falls
out of everything else gold is a
safeguard Birch gold group has thousands
of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau and
y'all know about birch Gold's free info
kit but for a limited time qualified
purchases can earn up to an additional
10 grand and precious metals for free
through July 31st check it out at
birchgold.com slash men speak to a burst
gold rep mention I sent you that's
birchgold.com /ban do it now the offer
only runs until July 30 force until July
31st terms of limitations apply ask your
sales representative for details as I
mentioned with the temperature in
politics so high the Supreme Court
retirement of Anthony Kennedy is raising
the temperature even higher and I
encourage people yesterday to calm down
about this the reason I encourage people
to calm down is because it is not the
job of Supreme Court according to
conservatives to implement their
preferred policy prescriptions the
Supreme Court is not going to rule
tomorrow that abortion is banned across
the land it was the Supreme Court that
ruled that abortion was legal across the
land because the leftist on the court
decided to use the supreme court as a
tool of their will instead of a tool of
judgment the same thing was true of
same-sex marriage when the Supreme Court
decided unilaterally that same-sex
marriage was now mandated by a document
that was ratified in 1791 and an
amendment that was ratified in 1868 okay
that was the Supreme Court that did that
the way conservatives view the Supreme
Court is that it's the job of the
Supreme Court to essentially get out of
the way when it comes to what states
have to do as so long as it is in so
long as it is in consonants with the
Constitution of the United States so the
Supreme Court is not an activist Supreme
Court when conservatives run it it
strikes down a lot fewer laws generally
it gets involved in in in national
mandates almost never but the fact is
that because the left has used the
Supreme Court is at school for so long
they think that now the right is gonna
use the Supreme Court as a club and what
they are most worried about of course is
the overturning of role
they're under the wildness impression
that 4o v weight is overturned that
immediately makes abortion illegal
across the United States would that it
were so but it is not hey the reality is
that if roe v wade is is reversed as it
should be then what happens that all of
these laws go back to the states and all
of these laws go back to the states and
so California will have abortion on
demand and Alabama will not that's
that's the way that this will work and
if you want an abortion you will simply
cross state lines and you'll go get an
abortion that that's that's the high
likelihood as to how this thing ends up
working out federalism ends up
prevailing unless there are some sort of
constitutional amendments or federal law
to bar abortion across the board which
you know would be hard to pass I think
um but that's not stopping the insane
rhetoric coming out of the left so the
left is in full panic mode I think one
of the reasons they're in full panic
mode is because again I think that they
thought that there was gonna be a
thousand-year rule by the left after
Obama they thought they're never losing
an election again so they so why would
we even worry about Donald Trump and
then it turns out not only do they lose
the election they lost the Senate the
house most state houses in most
governorships and they turned around and
looked around said wait this isn't the
America Obama promised well Whoopi
Goldberg is leading the charge against
against overturning roe v wade the level
of insanity in this rhetoric is
extraordinarily high and again I just I
don't know why any of this is good for
the country but here's Whoopi Goldberg
going after Meghan McCain okay Meghan
McCain is it not a she's a Republican
Meghan McCain is certainly not an
extreme conservative by any stretch of
the imagination and Meghan McCain is a
moderate conservative the best and
Whoopi Goldberg is telling Meghan McCain
he's pro-life to get out of her vagina
which I can safely say most people are
very happy to do here is here is Whoopi
Goldberg if you take my right away from
me to judge what I do for my family and
my body I've got a little problem with
that you got a problem you know you
don't want people to take your guns
let's get out of my behind get out of my
vagina
okay and no one wants to be there will
be I that's that's not a thing and and
again and this is the the idea that that
Republicans are suddenly going to be
doing Handmaid's Tale stuff that they're
interested in putting things up Whoopi
Goldberg's vagina in search for baby she
cannot have because I assume she's
postmenopausal I like what but then but
this is the the tenor of the rhetoric
that we have now reached now with that
said right and and what like Nancy
Pelosi says the same thing right Nancy
Pelosi says that the Supreme Court is
doing violence to our democracy violence
to our democracy well if you're going to
equate speech with violence is it any
wonder when violence is is a response to
that when people say okay well the
Supreme Court's turn violence to us what
if we do violence to the Supreme Court
this is the problem that I have with a
lot of what's going on in college
campuses I visit twenty five thirty
college campuses a year and when people
say my speech is violence
well then their answer very often is
okay aunt Eva's answer is well what if I
use violence against the violence that
is the speech Nancy Pelosi by the way
said that the Supreme Court did violence
to our democracy how they did violence
to our democracy by saying that the
government could not point a gun at you
and force you to pay dues to a union
that's really what she's saying here and
then and then we're hearing from the
left that it's Trump whose rhetoric is
extreme um guys do own mirrors here's
Nancy Pelosi with its decision that
didn't announced yesterday the Supreme
Court became supreme Corp their decision
does violence to the First Amendment
cheapening it and using it stretching it
as a rationale for this decision okay so
there we go
you know it's it the Supreme Court is
doing violence now and yet again the
left will blame Donald Trump for
shootings at a Maryland newspaper so
it's it's all it's all good it's all
good everything's fine you know nothing
to worry about here now as far as the
Supreme Court seat
the only possibility that President
Trump does not get his pick that he
wants for the Supreme Court seat is if
Susan Collins and Lisa Murkowski who are
the two most left-leaning members of the
Senate caucus decide that they are going
to somehow hold up any Trump nominee
unless that Trump nominee pledges fealty
to roe v wade I don't think that's
actually what's going to happen here
Susan Collins says that roe v-- wade is
set a law because she is wrong but but
here's Susan Collins making that case
from my perspective
roe v-- wade is an important precedent
and it is settled law okay it's always
funny how people say things are settled
law when they like those things but the
minute they don't like those things
those things have to be overturned so it
turns out that one of the things that
was settled law in the United States for
legitimately the entire history of the
United States is that traditional
marriage was the only way marriage was
done nobody said that was settled law
the minute that Oberkfell happened it
was settled law the minute roe v wade
happened it was settled law according to
people like Susan Collins but is Susan
Collins releasing Murkowski actually
going to hold up the show on president
Trump's Supreme Court Peck I think not
and the reason is because no Supreme
Court possibility is going to answer
straight the question as to whether they
would overturn roe v wade this is one of
the sad outcomes of how we've done
judicial nominations since the Bork era
which is that every judge now has the
the absolute interest in hiding their
opinions for as long as possible so they
don't get bored right just judge Bork
who was nominated for the Supreme Court
by President Reagan he was very obvious
about his opinions and he openly
answered questions about legal cases and
then he was basically thrown out and not
given a Supreme Court seat because of it
thanks to the machination and people
like Joe Biden and Ted Kennedy well the
reality is that most judges now aren't
simply going to evade the question so
none of these judges are going to have
to answer straight the question as to
whether they would overturn roe v wade
because no judge has had to answer that
question in the last 25 years so so I
think that this is going to end up with
with Murkowski and Collins holding up a
trump nominee I don't I really don't
which is a good thing so Trump ought to
go for broke
Trump oughtta go for the most the most
originalist textualist judge you can
find you should go for the the home run
because there's no excuse from not to
get a home run out of all this okay so
in just a second we're gonna jump into
the mailbag but before that you're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire comm and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe to daily wire comm when you do
you get the rest of this show live it
means that you also get the rest of the
Andrew Clavin show live you get the rest
of the michael Mol's show live also you
can get the amount Walsh show right so
Matt Walsh does a show if you didn't
know about that Mount Walsh's show he
does it actually from like his basement
or from his car and it is quite I think
it's pretty good you should go check it
out
over at Daley wire.com you can also
check it out at youtube so go check that
out as well as comments for our site one
more popular columnist at daily wear
comm and get that with the $9.99
subscription and be part of the mailbag
so if you want to write me a question
right now live now is the time to
subscribe also for $99 a year you get
all of those things and this the leftist
here's hot were called tumblr which has
been overflowing with liberal tears the
entire the entire week really so go
check that out and it is wondrous plus
check it out because when you subscribe
to our YouTube or to our order to our
iTunes page when you do all that you
also get the Sunday special and we have
a great Sunday special coming up this
Sunday with Adam Carolla we have some
really awesome ones coming up in future
weeks as well I can't wait to announce
them to you because they're really just
awesome but go check all that out we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's do some mailbag he
has been a long week let's let's take a
little bit of time with the mailbag this
week so if you got live questions now is
the time to send them in John Rice hi
Ben
I was wondering if since the first
amendment dictates the Congress cannot
make a while restricting the freedom of
expression could the left make such laws
such as hate speech religious expression
restrictions at the state level and have
them be upheld by the Supreme Court yes
I wish we could vote for Supreme Court
justices you'd be my top choice thanks
love the show and your work John okay so
the First Amendment did that so here's
the route so there are two questions
here one is does the First Amendment as
it currently as it is currently
constituted does it stop hate speech
laws religious expression restrictions
etc the answer there is yes unless the
left takes hold of the court and uses
the court as a club to beat to death the
First Amendment like a horse in the
street but hate speech laws are
unconstitutional because there's no
actual definition of hate speech there's
people on the left you think that might
show every day is hate speech it does
not but they're idiots and they think
that and so they could try to outlaw in
my speech right in the state of
California presumably they would try to
outlaw it if I say on the show that a
man is a man and a woman is a woman and
a man can't become a woman then they
would try to outlaw that okay that would
be a violation of the First Amendment
now you're asking about what's called
incorporation doctrine so incorporation
doctrine is the idea the First Amendment
really should have applied only to the
federal government clearly that's true
this is why we have state constitutions
not just a federal constitution I state
of California has its own constitution
Texas has its own Constitution every
state has its own constitution that have
sort of mirror provisions with regard to
the First Amendment protecting you know
the state version of the First Amendment
originally the federal constitutions did
not protect free speech rights at the
state level so the state actually could
quash First Amendment rights at the
state level and the federal government
would have nothing to say about it then
there's something called the
incorporation doctrine I the the
incorporation doctrine really came about
the early 20th century when people began
trying to use the 14th amendment which
applies to the states to read the First
Amendment into law so the the 14th
amendment suggests that everyone at the
state level not just the federal level
everyone at the state level is is
guaranteed due process an equal
protection of the laws and the Supreme
Court basically said well we're also
going to say the due process requires
that your First Amendment rights be
respected now I don't think that
incorporation doctrine actually is
legally justifiable even if I like the
outcome on a lot of it but the
but it has been incorporated so the
first amendment is incorporated the
second member has been incorporated all
of the first amendments have been
incorporated into state constitutions
essentially or two into state law via
the so-called incorporation doctrine
brian says - I was born and raised in
the Midwest I am visiting California for
the first time
my perception hasn't always been that
California's a bastion of liberal and
hippie ideals haven't been here those
stereotypes have been confirmed from the
feces on the street to the rampant
homeless to the trash strewn streets the
liberal ideal is everywhere my question
is how did California turn from a state
created by the pioneer spirit the state
that gave us Ronald Reagan to this
thanks and Shapiro for Supreme Court
well I'm glad that the groundswell for
me for a Supreme Court has been so
successful if it doesn't work out then
I'll just be here with you every day
crying myself to sleep but the but the
reality is that California started down
this sort of path in the 1990s the the
last kind of gasp of California
conservatism was was Pete Wilson and
then after Pete Wilson
we got gray Davis and Arnold
Schwarzenegger and there had been a
significant move in the California
Legislature to the left over the
previous decades anyway
California had always been a little more
liberal than the rest of the country I
would say although for a while it had
sort of a conservative streak with
regard to the governor's that it elected
that ended in the 1990s there's a solid
case to be made that is the demographics
in California shifted so to to the
electoral politics that that as the the
state became more immigrant based that a
lot of those new immigrants were voting
Democrat more often and that changed the
constituency in California pretty
massively I think that case is pretty
good I don't think it's it's just
positive County Texas for example has
had a lot of immigrants as well the
Hispanic population in Texas is growing
massively Texas remains a very red state
but California is is also extremely
urban in the sense that most of the
population lives in like two or three
big cities right most of the population
lives in LA or San Francisco and big
cities tend to tend to toward the left
just generally speaking now Phillip says
why do we have gun laws any gun watch it
infringed on the amendment we should be
able to conceal open carry anywhere in
public how our gun was not infringing on
the Second Amendment well the general
the general traditional sort of
interpretation of the Second Amendment
is very similar to the interpretation of
the First Amendment which is the first
amendment which guarantees freedom of
speech and says the Congress shall make
no law abridging freedom of speech that
does not apply to you defamation it does
not apply to libel it's
applied to incitement to violence that
virtually every amendment has certain
curtailments of the amendment that allow
for Public Policy to be made the
question is are those public policy
curtailments as minimal as humanly
possible in order to achieve the public
policy that is being pursued there is no
such thing as any right that is
unchecked that is untrammeled even First
Amendment rights right freedom of
religion is not untrammeled given the
fact that if you pass a neutral facially
neutral statute that has nothing to with
religion that may not necessarily
violate religious rights even if those
religious rights are in fact curtailed
by the operation of that law injustice
has been what do you think about the
warning of Uribe's manof in 1970 that
the time would be a crisis period of
ideological subversion I don't know
enough about that to answer that
question that is extraordinarily
specific so I will check that out and
get back to you Justin Brown says deer
seem to be just as Shapiro is there an
actual difference between sex and gender
or is this an artificial distinction
created by the left thanks and love the
show well the answer is that it is an
artificial distinction created by the
left the way they've defined so the left
does this this thing where they say
there's a difference between sex which
is your biological sex and gender which
is the way that your sort of your sex
manifests so in other words that are you
an effeminate man well then maybe you
aren't and that your feminine see is now
part of your gender if you're a woman
who likes to wear pants and a butch
haircut then this is some part of your
gender right so they create this sort of
false distinction they use the word
gender to encompass all of this but then
they do this weird trick where they say
gender is sex
so we'll say sex is not gender but
gender is sex so in other words gender
has nothing to do with your biology
right you can be a biological male but
your gender can be female because you
can be really a feminine you want to
wear dresses and you are a female in
your mind but your sex is male but your
gender is female right and this is what
this is when you are non cisnormative
for your non cisgender the gender that
you express is is the jet is not the sex
that you were born with or the gender
you were assigned at Birth as they like
to put it and then they will say but
it's biological this was built-in so in
other words sex is not built-in but
gender is built-in which makes no sense
at all and they also like to say that
sex and gender are completely
disconnected so there are all these
inherent contradictions in the way that
the left defines gender if the left's
just wanted to say listen there's your
sex your biological sex and then there's
how that biological sex manifests in
your daily behavior there's nothing even
remotely arguable but arguable about
that of course that's true but the
attempt is to say
that you are a gendered female but a
biological male and excel file aaj eclis
intersex there is no basis for this
whatsoever
there's no basis for this because the
left's argument is that if I think of
myself as a female I am a female they're
not saying that if I did a brain scan
and it turned out that my brain worked
like a female then I'm a female they're
saying that the way that that manifests
in my behavior and my choices in my
thinking that's what makes me a female
and that cannot be sustained on any
logical level Jo says hey Ben in my once
a week graduate class the professor
students bashed Trump for about two
hours and then watch Justin Trudeau
YouTube videos for another hour I'm
sorry to hear that and I'm sorry for the
loss of your brain cells the late
lamented brain cells you used to have as
a former teacher who's conservative I
didn't find it very difficult to stay
away from preaching my political agenda
why do you think the Left seems to be
guilty of doing this much more regularly
and blatantly in the classroom thanks so
I think the reason is because many
people on the Left have a very difficult
time distinguishing between their
opinion and fact I think this holds true
across political boundaries and they're
people on the right who have this
trouble too but when you live in an echo
chamber like the educational system is
then you start to think that everything
that you think about life is actually a
fact because all your friends believe
the same thing this is why you'll hear
people say things like Trump is a Nazi
that's just a fact you can't argue with
that well no that's an opinion and I
certainly can't argue with that
you know there are certain things that
are facts two plus two equals four this
is a fact it is not a fact that Trump is
a Nazi that is an opinion and a wrong
opinion in my in my belief of that so
it's I think that echo chambers tend to
create a belief that your opinion is a
reflection of reality rather than just a
subjective interpretation of reality
Greg says hey Ben
if mightly were nominated for supreme
court who would he have to resign from
the Senate before confirmation which
would complicate the numbers even more
or would he still be a senator and be
able to vote on his own confirmation
well that's actually really unclear so
theoretically he could recuse himself
and I'm not sure that he actually has to
recuse himself so he theoretically could
vote for himself even if he were to
recuse himself that slot would
immediately be filled by the governor of
Utah who's a Republican so he'd have a
Republican senator in there
voting for it plus the Republicans have
50 votes they would gain another couple
of votes from the Democrats I think Mike
Lee would be easily confirmed I don't
think there's a lot of question about
that Jeremy says hey Ben since Rho V
weight is now front and center in the
news would you please explain the legal
argument of the majority opinion in the
ruling and what about it you think is so
flawed thanks so much
a huge fan of the show okay so we can go
through roe v wade in a little bit
detail here let me actually bring up the
case so roe v-- wade was the case in
which the Supreme Court decided that
abortions had to be legalized across the
nation the case was Roe who later it
turns out become a pro-life person
sought to terminate her pregnancy by
abortion is according to OS org which is
a really good place to summarize these
cases Texas law prohibited abortion
except to save the pregnant woman's life
after granting cert certiorari the court
heard arguments twice the first time
Roe's attorney could not locate the
constitutional hook of her argument for
justice Potter Stewart her opponent J
Floyd misfired from the start wedington
sharpen her constitutional argument in
the second round her new opponent came
under strong questioning from justice
Potter Stewart and Thurgood Marshall the
court held that a woman's right to an
abortion fell within the right to
privacy
recognizing Griswold versus Connecticut
protected by the Fourteenth Amendment so
as I pointed out yesterday I said
emanations from penumbra's and somebody
said right that's from Griswold v
Connecticut that's an earlier case where
as well versus Connecticut was a case in
the 1960s in which the court decided
that the amendment 1958 in which the
court decided that there was a right to
contraception for the contraceptives for
single people so I believe was Vermont
had to sire Connecticut rather was
Griswold v Connecticut it was
Connecticut decided that there's a lot
on the books that single people could
not obtain contraceptives and the court
said there's a right to privacy that
allows you to buy contraceptives now
where in the Constitution does it say
you have a right to buy contraceptives
regardless of your marital status it
doesn't right none of that is there but
they say there are emanations from
penumbra's what they meant was that if
you look at the Fourth Amendment search
and seizure provisions and you sort of
look at them with squinty eyes kind of
like a magic eye puzzle then you can get
out of the prohibition of unreasonable
search and seizure that there's a right
to privacy and then from that
generalized rights of privacy we can
then read into that that there is a
right for you to buy a contraceptive if
you're a single person and I think that
decision is wrongly decided and by the
way I think single people should
certainly be able to buy contraceptives
but this is why I think legislators are
not judges and judges are not
legislatures with that said you know the
stupidity of the idea that the
Constitution mandates that is evidence
there is no right to privacy generalized
right to privacy in the Constitution
there are several different aspects of
what you could term rights privacy
they're right against unreasonable
search and seizure the right to free
speech right there are certain things
that you could look at the Constitution
and say that has to do with privacy but
there's no general
right to privacy you can then take and
implement and it certainly would not
apply to a rather non private decision
like having an abortion with the use of
the medical provider right it's so funny
when it comes to medical provision of
services the left believes that is
completely public Act right the left
believes that the government should pay
for that then my dealings with my doctor
should be subject to government
regulation every single way except when
it comes to abortion in which case that
is completely private you have no
business saying anything about it
so roe v wade was decided on right to
privacy grounds and then they made a
secondary argument roe v wade about the
issue of viability the viability of the
fetus and so they said that laws in the
third trimester might be okay because if
you have laws in the third trimester
then you're talking about the viability
the fetus may be the fetus can survive
on its own so maybe the fetus has some
rights
they basically fudge the entire decision
it's it's one of the worst
constitutional decisions in American
history just from a purely legal
perspective it's incredibly incredibly
stupid so there is your brief summary of
roe v wade anybody who says roe v wade
is legally justifiable has never read
the case it's an insane case or they're
so ideologically driven that they
believe that anything is justifiable so
long as they reach the the conclusion
they want at least has a been in the
last episode of the conversation you
said you're hot what doctor wife likes
to rip on you which prompted me to ask
this very important question has the
thug-life also chosen her i would say
that the tug life chooses her a little
less frequently than life chooses
me but the thug life lives within her
just as the doctrine lives within Amy
Barrett who I hope president Trump
nominates for the Supreme Court the the
thug life lives within my wife it comes
out at random times my wife is
legitimately the nicest person ever and
like anyone in the offices met her knows
she is in extraordinarily nice human
being and it is so funny because every
so often it's usually once every couple
of years she will say something that is
so cutting and I'll look at her and
we'll both just start laughing because
it's so out of character it's really
really funny yeah I had to marry a nice
person otherwise our kids would have
been just the worst
so Jeremy says let's see we didn't turn
ready Spencer says which Supreme Court
cases in your opinion contributed most
of the expansion of federal power beyond
the constraints defined in the
Constitution a furthermore aside from
the rulings you obviously violated the
civil rights of minorities Dred Scott
Plessy Korematsu which cases would you
rank is the worst three in Supreme Court
history
Wow okay so there been a lot of bad
decisions in Supreme Court history as I
mentioned Dred Scott Plessy Korematsu I
would say Wickard
Shelburne is what is one of the worst
cases in Supreme Court history that is a
case in which a guy was growing grain
for his own consumption in 1940's
America under FDR and FDR had passed all
of these new laws that attempted to
restrict the amount of grain that you
could actually grow because he was
trying to artificially boost the price
of grain on behalf the farmers and this
person said wait a second like I'm not
in working to be pho burn the the farmer
said I'm not even growing this for
interstate shipment right I'm not
shipping this across state lines what
does the federal government have to do
with me growing grain for my own
consumption right or even growing grain
for intrastate commerce like I'm just
trading it inside the state what does
the federal government have to do with
that what could it be Phil Burton said
anything you do that could possibly have
an impact on a market is now considered
interstate commerce for purposes of
federal regulation well that basically
means is anything you do any day has
federal implications which was an insane
it's an insane standard ray I mean that
standard basically suggests that you are
every time I flush the toilet that has
an impact on the water prices in the
state of California and that water price
in the state of California has an impact
on federal water regulation and
therefore the federal government has the
right to regulate how I flush my toilet
legitimately this is what the case was
in Wickard V filburn the Commerce Clause
which was designed to constrain the
federal government has instead been read
to allow the federal government to run
roughshod over everybody's rights as far
as humanly possible so Wickard V filburn
is an awful awful case other cases that
are really bad there is a case called
Skinner versus Oklahoma that is that is
famously awful Skinner versus Oklahoma
if I'm not mistaking the case was
decided by was it Oliver Wendell Holmes
this was 19 well this was yeah this is
I'm trying to remember who actually
wrote the decision in this it was let's
see written by William O Douglas so this
was a law that permitted the sorry
Skinner versus Oklahoma has correctly
decided it overruled another decision
okay so the the other decision that it
overruled was the three generations of
imbeciles are enough decision by Oliver
Wendell Holmes I'm trying member the
name of the case settle or screw it up
that would be buck vs. Bell so buck vs.
Bell 1927 is the one that I'm thinking
of that's really bad not Skinner versus
Oklahoma buck vs. Bell was a decision
written by Oliver Wendell Holmes Oliver
Wendell Holmes was a proponent of
eugenics and the case
basically said that a state statute
permitting compulsorily compulsory
sterilization of the mentally disabled
for the protection of health of the
state did not violate the Constitution
of the United States yes an insane
decision as a fully crazy decision a
decision so bad the Nazis actually cited
it at the Nuremberg trials to show that
they were not outside the mainstream of
Western political thought when they
started using sterilization against
their political opponents so buck vs.
Bell would be up there so other than
Wickard buck vs. Bell and I mentioned
Roe already so Roe I think is is
obviously you know one of the one of the
if it's not the worst Supreme Court
decision in American history it's top -
it's either it's either Dred Scott or
Roe ok Paul says one aspect of the Bible
many people I know criticize is that of
slavery in the book as well as being
degraded to women such as Genesis where
Adam is to be Eve's master I was hoping
that you could explain this thanks okay
so a couple of things about slavery in
the Bible so slavery in the Bible is not
mandatory right there's nothing the
Bible that says you have to own slaves
in fact the Bible has pretty strict
restrictions on how slavery is supposed
to operate if you own somebody who is
sold into slavery and they are a fellow
Jew right then the way that it works in
in the Bible is that you must release
them after seven years and if they don't
want to be released then you actually
have to pierce their ear with an awl
because the idea is that they should
want to be released they shouldn't to be
a free person also the the restrictions
on slavery in the Bible suggests that
you have to treat your slaves with an
extraordinary amount of care and decency
now all of that said is slavery in the
Bible a wonderful thing no but the
question is and this is a general
question about the Bible obviously is
what was designed for the time and what
is designed for now and it's pretty
clear in the Bible that what the Bible
is trying to do because it's speaking to
a particular group of people in a
particular time in place it is trying to
curb slavery it's moving the direction
of curbing slavery just as the
Constitution of the United States has
provisions outlawing the importation of
slaves after 1808 the and that is to
move away from slavery not to move
toward slavery the Bible is trying to
move people away from slavery and has
heavy restrictions on how slaves are to
be handled and how they're to be taken
and again slavery is universal in the
world at that time it is not that it is
a it is a thing that only exists under
the Bible it is something that is
literally universal so when you talk
about something in is literally
universal throughout all of human
history and it's only recently
changed then you have to ask yourself
was this document and something to move
us away from slavery or was it
attempting to enshrine slavery there's a
reason that all of the abolitionists use
the Bible as the impetus for their
anti-slavery zeal then that goes all the
way up to and including John Brown who
actually use the Bible as an excuse to
go and kill slave owners so the the idea
of the Bible is a pro-slavery document I
think is a wild mystery of the Bible as
to the idea that women are mistreated in
the Bible again then when it comes to
some of the laws with regard to women in
the Bible you have to see them in the
context of the time which is to say they
are wildly progressive for the time that
in which they're written and as far as
the idea that Adam is to be Eve's master
well know her curse right she's cursed
with the idea that he's cursed with the
idea that he's gonna have to till the
land and then it's not that Eve has to
submit herself to Adam the idea is that
the curse is that he that Adam is gonna
lord it over her and that she is going
to long for him nonetheless that's a
description that is not normative it's
not an order that Eve has to become Adam
slave right that she's that he is
supposed to be her master read the text
what the text actually says is that your
curse is that he will lord it over you
it's a descriptive thing the description
is that men are gonna treat you like
crap and you're still gonna want to be
with them all right which seems to be
fairly accurate as to how men have acted
for most of human history so you know
the state of absolute equality that
existed in the endemic free x-rays ellic
period was it was ended with the fall
and the basically what the Bible is
saying is that your curse is that this
is the way the world is and it is your
job to try and get back into Eden right
is your job to to try and make your your
life but it's men's job not to treat
women that way and it's woman's job to
to be better human beings as well so I
just I think again that's that's a
deliberate miss reading of the Bible
okay so that brings us to the end of the
mailbag so let's get to a quick thing
that I like and then some things that I
hate already so the thing that I like
today is a book by Antonin Scalia if you
are into constitutional jurisprudence
then one of the classics in the field is
is Justice Scalia's a matter of
interpretation federal courts and the
law
it describes his judicial philosophy I
would say that my only quibble with
Justice Scalia is the Justice Scalia was
a little too attached to sorry decisis I
don't like starter decisis the idea that
the case has been decided precedents I
don't think the president ought to rule
because I think there's been a lot of
bad precedents I just mentioned a couple
of them I think buck developed buck V
Bell
a bad precedent overturned by Skinner
versus Oklahoma and that is a a
worthwhile way to the bottom line is if
a decision is bad it's bad but Justice
Scalia obviously one of the great minds
ever to sit on the court certainly one
of best writers ever to sit on the court
and his book a matter of interpretation
is a really good description of how it
was that he thought so go check it out
Antonin Scalia's book a matter of
interpretation okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so you'll recall
there's a guy named Michael Bennett
Michael Bennett was a place for the
Seattle Seahawks and he levied a bunch
of accusations of racism against the Las
Vegas police and it turns out that he
was not telling the truth about this so
Michael Bennett suggested that the
police had had attacked him for no
reason in Las Vegas just because he was
black what actually happens the police
received a report of an active shooter
and Michael Bennett started crouching
and then hiding behind a slot machine he
ran to hide behind a slot machine and
when officers took note he jumped up and
took off in a full sprint and failed to
listen to officer commands to stop he
said this was all because of racism and
now he's trying to lecture President
Trump about racism if Trump is really
wanted to listen to you know find out
why would take attorney that would be
something that I'd be down to do if it's
an opportunity to change the way that
America is or change my communities I'm
always going to take those opportunities
to express my knees and express them the
passion of other people okay so listen
I'm fine with people talking about
racism I'm fine with people talking to
President Trump about racism I find
Trump wants to talk with people about
racism but using people who have lied
about police officers as the
spokespeople for the anti racism
movement seems deeply counterproductive
that is not how we are going to reach
any sort of consensus in the country and
they're better spokespeople for the anti
racism cause than people who fit about
police officers for political gain okay
well we will be after next week we may
have a new Supreme Court justice nominee
on our hands by that point so keep an
eye out for that I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Alex and Garo audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018